so can you give a whirlwind overview of
the
products that kamehameha provides like
uh throughout its history and today
i mean yeah the past ones aren't really
that interesting it's kind of just been
refinement of the same idea uh
the real only product we sell today is
the comma two which is a piece of
hardware
with cameras um so the comma two
i mean you can think about it kind of
like a person ah you know when future
hardware will probably be even more and
more person-like
um so it has uh you know eyes
ears a mouth a brain
uh and a way to interface with the car
does it have consciousness
just kidding that was a trick question
because i don't have consciousness
either
me and the common two are the same
they're the same i have a little more
compute than that
it only has like the same computer
interesting b
uh you know you're more efficient energy
wise
for the compute you're doing far more
efficient energy-wise
huh 20 pay flaps 20 watts crazy you lack
consciousness
sure do you fear death you do you want
immortality what's up you're does comedy
i fear death
i don't think so of course it does it
very much fears while it fears negative
loss
oh yeah okay
so comma it's a comma two when did that
come out that was a year ago
no two uh early this year
wow time it feels like yeah
2020 feels like uh it's taken 10 years
to get to the end it's a long year
it's a long year so um
what uh what's the sexiest thing about
comma
2 feature-wise so i mean maybe you can
also link on like
what is it like what's its purpose
because there's a hardware there's a
software component
you've mentioned the sensors but also
like what is it of its features and
capabilities
i think our slogan summarizes it well uh
comma slogan is make driving chill
i love it okay yeah i mean it is
you know if you like cruise control
imagine cruise control but much much
more so it can uh
do adaptive cruise control things which
is like slow down for cars in front of
it maintain a certain speed and you can
also
do lane keeping so stay in the lane and
do it better and better and better over
time it's very much
machine learning based so this camera is
there's a driver facing camera
too that's the
um what else is there what am i thinking
so the hardware versus software so
open pilot versus the actual hardware of
the device
what's can you draw that distinction
what's one what's the other i mean the
hardware is pretty much a cell phone
with a few additions a cell phone with a
cooling system
and with a car interface connected to it
and as by cell phone you mean uh like
qualcomm snapdragon
uh yeah the current hardware is the
snapdragon 821
uh it has wi-fi radio it has an lte
radio it has a screen
we use every part of the cell phone and
then the interface with the car is
specific to the car so you keep
supporting more and more cars um yeah so
the interface to the car i mean the
device itself just has four can buses
has four can interfaces on it that are
connected through the usb port to the
phone
um and then yeah on those four can buses
uh you connect it to the car and there's
a little harness to do this cars are
actually surprisingly similar
so canon is the the protocol by which
cars communicate
and then you're able to read stuff and
write stuff to be able to control the
car depending on the car
so what's the software side what's open
pilot
um so i mean open pilot is the hardware
is pretty simple compared to open pilot
open pilot
is uh
well so you have a machine learning
model which
it's an open pilot it's a you know it's
a blob uh it's just a blob of weights
it's not like people are like oh it's
closed source i'm like it's a blob of
weights what do you expect
um you know primarily neural network
based
ul open pilot is all the software kind
of around that neural network
that if you have a neural network that
says here's where you want to send the
car
open pilot actually goes and executes
all of that
it cleans up the input to the neural
network it cleans up the output and
executes on it so it connects
the glue that connects everything
together runs the sensors does a bunch
of calibration for the neural network
does you know deals with like you know
if the car is on a banked road
uh you have to counter steer against
that and the neural network can't
necessarily know that by looking at the
picture
um so you do that with with other
sensors infusion and localizer
openpilot also is responsible for
sending the data up to our servers so we
can learn from it
logging it recording it running the
cameras thermally managing the device
managing the disk space on the device
managing all the resources in the device
so what um since we last spoke i don't
remember when maybe a year ago maybe a
little bit longer
how uh has open pilot improved we did
exactly what i promised you
i promised you that by the end of the
year we you'd be able to remove
the lanes um the lateral policy
is now uh almost completely end-to-end
you can turn the lanes off and it will
drive drive slightly worse on the
highway if you turn the lanes off
but you can turn the lanes off and it
will drive well
trained completely end to end on user
data
and this year we hope to do the same for
the longitudinal policy that's the
interesting thing
is you're not doing you don't appear to
be you can correct me you don't appear
to be doing lean
detection or lane marking detection or
kind of the segmentation task or
any kind of object detection task you're
doing what's
traditionally more called like
end-to-end learning
so and trained on actual behavior of
drivers
when they're driving the car manually
this is hard to do you know it's not
supervised learning
yeah but uh so the nice thing is there's
a lot of data so it's hard and easy
right it's uh we have a lot of high
quality data yeah
like more than you need in the center
well we way more than we do we have way
more data than we need
i mean it's it's an interesting question
actually because
in terms of amount you have more than
you need
but the you know driving is full of edge
cases so how do you
select the data you train on
i i think this is an interesting open
question like what's
what's the cleverest way to select data
that's the question tesla is probably
working on
uh that's i mean the entirety of machine
learning can be they don't seem to
really care they just kind of select
data but i feel like that
if you want to solve if you want to
create intelligent systems you have to
pick data well
right and so would you have any hints
ideas of how to do it well
so in some ways that is the definition i
like of reinforcement learning versus
supervised learning
in supervised learning the weights
depend on the data
right um and this is obviously true but
the
uh in reinforcement learning the data
depends on the weights
yeah right and actually both ways that's
poetry so
it's brilliant how does it know what
data to turn on well let it pick uh
we're not there yet but that's the
eventual
so you're thinking this almost like a
reinforcement learning framework
we're going to do rl on the world every
time a car
makes a mistake user disengages we train
on that and do our all in the world
ship out a new model that's an epoch
right
and uh for now you're not
doing the elon style promising that it's
going to be fully autonomous you really
are sticking to level two
and like it's supposed to be supervised
it is definitely supposed to be
supervising reinforce the fact that it's
supervised
um we look at our rate of improvement
in disengagements um openpilot now has
an unplanned
engagement about every 100 miles this is
up from 10 miles
like maybe
maybe uh maybe a year ago
yeah so maybe we've seen 10x improvement
in here but a hundred miles
is still a far cry from the hundred
thousand you're going to need
so you're going to somehow need to get
um
three more 10xs in there and you're
what's your intuition
i you're basically hoping that there's
exponential improvement built into the
baked into the cake somewhere well
that's even
i mean 10x is proven that's already
assuming exponential right there's
definitely exponential improvement
and i think when elon talks about
exponential like these things these
systems are going to exponentially
improve
just exponential doesn't mean you're
getting 100 gigahertz processors
tomorrow
right like it's going to still take a
while because the gap
between even our best system and humans
is still large
you